[موسيقى]
الارجنتين اول طرفين نهائي المونديال
بعدما انهت مغامرات كرواتيا الجريئه وقصت
عليها بثلاثيه نظيفه الاهداف جميعها وقال
عليها الاسطوره ميسي سواء بتسجيل او
الصناعه ليوم استمر للنهايه مباراه واحده
تفصلها عن اللقب الاغلى في مشاركته
الخامسه والاخيره
منتخب البرازيل حتى مجانين رونالدو متابعه
اللعبه المنصفون
وصول ميسي الى النهائي هذه المسيره تحتاج
الى تكريمه
ارادت كره القدم ان تحفظ هذا اللقب لتهديه
له في اخر ظهور يكون مشهد النهايه تكريما
لاحد اعظم من روضها في التاريخ على الجانب
الاخر رحلته لوكا مودريتش قائد كرواتيا في
كاس العالم انتهت لكنه سينافس على المركز
الثالث مع الخاسر من لقاء فرنسا والمغرب
يوم السبت
[موسيقى]
الارجنتين تفوز على كرواتيا وملامح نهائي
المونديال تتضح وكما اعتدنا اليكم بعض
الارقام والاحصائيات بعد هذا الانتصار
الارجنتين في نهائي المونديال للمره
السادسه في التاريخ وهو ثاني اكثر فريق
يصل هذا الدور بعد المانيا التي شاركت في
ثمانيه نهائيات من قبل جوليان هو اصغر من
يسجل هدفين في نصف نهائي المونديال بعد
الاسطوره البرازيليه بيليه في كاس العالم
عام
1958 ليو ميسي هو الاعلى تسجيلا للارجنتين
في كاس العالم برصيد 11 هدفا متخصصي
المواطنه
ميسي يصبح اللاعب الاول الذي يسجل ويصنع
خلال اربع مباريات متتاليه منذ نسخه عام
1966 ميرسي يصبح ثاني لاعب في تاريخ
المونديال يحقق افضل لاعب في اربع مباريات
بنسخه واحده والجديد بالذكر ان اول من حقق
ذلك كان ميسي ايضا في مونديال 2014 ينضم
الينا من الدوحه الزمنيه في الثقيل مراسل
صباح العربيه انا في يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
بدنا نسمعها المره اجواء مباراه الارجنتين
كرواتيا في الدوحه كيف كانت
همم
صيام واهلا نادين طبعا بالامس انا حضرت
المباراه كم مشجع وخط الثلج
قبل الملعب وفي الملعب وبعد
ههه
طبعا انا بكون في المقابله هذه كلها مبتسم
طبعا نادين تعرف في السبب همم امس كانت
الاجواء داخل
امس كانت الاجواء جدا جميله في الملعب
لاول مره استاد الوسيله وهو اكثر اكبر
ملعب في كاس العالم يمتلئ بالطاقه
الاستيعابيه الكامله كانت جماهير
الارجنتين هي اا ال- ال- الاغلبيه كان
هناك لبعض المشاهد اللي لفتت نظري انه كان
في مناوشات ما بين الجماهير البرازيليه
وايضا للجماهير الارجنتينيه يعني هناك
يعني بعض الجماهير البرازيليه ما زالت
متواجده وحضرت امس في همم في محيط الملعب
وقد تكون شهره حتى التذاكر اعتبار انه
البرازيل ستكون في نصف النهائي وكان تدعم
كرواتيا رغم ان كرواتيا اخر البرازيل في
المقابل همم الجماهير الارجنتينيه يعني
حتى رغم تاهولها الى النهائي لم تنسى
البرازيل وكاله اغلب في هتافاتها كنت
متواجد معهم طبعا اغلى بتباتها كانت موجهه
ضد البرازيل
اليوم يناير هل لاحظتوا انه الاستعدادات
بدات على قدم وساق منذ ليله امس استعدادا
لمباراه اليوم الحاسمه ايضا
بخصوص المنتخب المغربي توافد عدد كبير جدا
من الجماهير العربيه لدعم المنتخب المغربي
بشكل ملفد ودعيني احكي لك يعني قصه همم
قبل امس مساء شائعه في اوساط الجماعي
بالعربيه والجماهير المغربيه انه سيتم
توزيع تذاكر مجانيه في محيط ملعب همم
استاذ همم البيت الساعه 10:00 صباحا
بالامس تخيل ان الجماهير المغربيه
والجماهير العربيه
همم اغطيتها ونامت بالقرب من الملعب تاهبا
لاستلام التذاكر في العاشر صباحا وكانت هي
مجرد شائعه ولم يتسلم احد او لم يتم
توزيعه اي تذكره في محيط الملعب فهذا يعني
عكس لك جانب كبير من التوقف والحماس وهمم
والدعم الكبير الذي يحضر فيه المنتخب همم
وان شاء الله نحتفل همم تاهل المغرب الى
نهائي كاس العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك من الدوحه الجميله المراسل
صباح العربيه شكرا يا نايف